[Musik]
der bix das mantra von amazon.com und
seinem stürmischen gründer
von dem moment an als ich dort anfing
haben wir das gaspedal immer stärker
durch getreten der kühne unternehmer hat
die regeln des handels neu geschrieben
alle hatten es eilig bei der oper
internet die der stadt vergessen sie
seine strategie zahlte sich nicht immer
aus auch nach dem börsengang haben sich
die leute die finanzdaten angeguckt und
gesagt die werden das nicht schaffen
amazon.com war im dezember 95
tatsächlich
ungefähr für eine stunde wird clown
schachzügen baute jeff bezos amazon.com
auf und ramazan k wenn du eine frage
stellst auf die jf nicht wirklich
eingehen will dann ist die antwort die
du kriegst ein lachen
und land hat er jede menge geld gemacht
[Musik]
auf amazon kannst du alles kaufen vom
books bücher musik schuhe bis hin zu
kampfpanzern oder tichy hütten amazon
amazon ist der erfolgreichste online
händler der welt
und wird immer noch von dem mann geführt
der ihn gegründet hat
der einzige ort zu sein an dem man
praktisch alles kaufen kann dies auf dem
einzelhandelsmarkt erhältlich ist es war
ein entscheidender teil der
wachstumsstrategie des unternehmens
das öffentliche bild von jeff bezos ist
das eine super helden und das ist er ist
risiken eingegangen er hat probleme
gelöst und er hat milliarden von dollar
an vermögen angehäuft als privatperson
ist base zurück haben teils und der
öffentlichkeit und er lehnte es ab an
unserem programm teilzunehmen
wurde am 12 januar 1964 in albuquerque
new mexico geboren als sohn von jackie
joyner 17 jährigen gymnasiasten
kreis ließ sich von seinem leiblichen
vater scheiden und heiratete einen
kubanischen einwanderer und exxon erdöl
ingenieur
miguel adoptierte das vierjährige kind
welches beschrieb seine frühen computer
erfahrungen 2001 in einem interview mit
der academy of the achievement
eine firma news nach dieser kleinen
grundschule groß eröffnet
keiner der lehrer wusste im moment utah
bedient niemand wusste aber
es gab einen stapel
kann ich schon ein paar andere kinder
blieben nach dem unterricht und lernen
und das ding programm
als teenager versuchte sich base zum
ersten mal als unternehmer mit einem
sommercamp mit den schwerpunkten
wissenschaft und literatur
fünf studenten meldeten sich an für 150
dollar pro kopf
1986 schloss er sein elektrotechnik und
informatik studium an der princeton
university mit summa cum laude ab
microsd-karten ist redakteur bei
business insider dass und berichtet seit
sechs jahren amazon
bekam einen job bei einem hedgefonds
namens die show er wollte nicht im
finanzwesen arbeiten sondern als
computer programmierer und die show war
genau das der hedgefond basierte auf
algorithmen und der art von technologie
für die sich besseres interessierte
es war nicht das einzige das ihn
interessiert hat er stieß auf eine
statistik die ihn überrascht es dass das
internet pro jahr um 2.300
einfach besessen von dieser zahl der
saison sah sich die 20 größten
versandhändlern und witterte seine
chance im internet
chris anderson damals chefredakteur des
magazins wired
diesen technologischen tsunami kommt der
ganz neue vertriebskanäle schaffen würde
er würde die wirtschaft neu definieren
und die art und weise ändern wie wir
kauften und verkauften
die frage war in welchem bereich sollten
wir das anwenden die antwort waren
bücher eine wahre für die es keinen
umfassenden katalogs ist im juli 1994
kündigte er seinen sicheren job an der
wall street um seinen traum zu
verwirklichen
eine der ersten online buchhandlungen
der welt his first investors seiner
ersten investoren warum seine eltern die
mir begegnet
erste frage meines vaters war was ist
das internet nicht
auf die firma oder das konzept gewettet
im sommer 94 machten sich base und seine
frau mackenzie auf den weg in den staat
washington
bewaffnet mit 300.000 dollar von seinen
eltern die technologie expertin esther
dyson ist vorsitzende der
investorenfirma adventure holding welche
logik es gibt viele leute die die
wallstreet verlassen um eigene startups
zu gründen aber jessica anders werde
viel erfahrung gesammelt und dann hat er
etwas erstaunliches geschaffen
und seine frau ließen sich in bellevue
washington nieder und stellten zwei
programmierer
des tales erzählt er darüber in einer
rede am lake forest
fand ein haus das als geschäftigen
könnte ist eine garage das passe es gibt
doch all diese geschichten und startup
zu garagen
das war nicht ganz legitim weil es eine
umfunktionierte anbau garage war aber
sie war nicht isoliert es waren wirklich
keine beeindruckenden büros
die firma
nach dem scheinbar endlosen fluss in
südamerika mit seinen unzähligen
nebenflüssen am 16 juli 95 öffnete
amazon.com seine virtuellen türen
james markus war mitarbeiter nummer 55
er sollte damals buchbesprechungen
schreiben die nichts weiter als eine
liste von titeln ein als ich mir die
website angeguckt habe um zu sehen ob
ich da wirklich arbeiten will stellte
ich fest wie rudimentär sie war es gab
eine titelseite mit einer bunten
mischung von büchern aber das
bemerkenswerteste war es gab einen
riesigen katalog mit mehreren
hunderttausend titeln wir aber gar
keinen inhalt hatte
amazon.com hatte kein werbe budget die
ersten umsätze wurden ausschließlich
über mundpropaganda erzielt
geschäftsführer
es war wirklich von anfang an ganz
anders
waren nicht im silicon valley sie waren
in seattle und sie haben auch bei diesen
ganzen hype nicht mitgemacht und jeden
tag pressemitteilungen herausgegeben
doch die seite setzte sich durch
innerhalb eines monats hatte amazon
kunden in allen 50 bundesstaaten und 45
weiteren ländern
hat amazon gut geführt er war
organisiert überstand den vertrieb in
ihren verstand des menschen zum kaufen
zu motivieren ist hinter tat die dinge
mit viel liebe zum detail
das ziel könnte in einer einfachen zeile
zusammengefasst
war ein mantra und auch eine
strategische entscheidung ich alles
musste gedopt sein das ganze wachstum
musste gedopt sein
von 1999 bis 2001 manager für
geschäftsentwicklung bei amazon
alle hatten es eilig das internet zu
erobern als ecommerce marktanteile zu
kommen
wie können wir die marke amazon
etablieren und das geschäft ausbauen
herbergs kosten der wettbewerber und
innerhalb eines sehr kleinen zeitfenster
die strategie zahlte sich aus von den
1996 hat er das unternehmen einen umsatz
von 15,7 millionen dollar die gewinne
wurden dadurch gesteigert dass amazon
den meisten kunden steuerfreies
einkaufen an bord
was uns ausmacht ist die große auswahl
und der komfort liefern direkt bis zur
haustür und wir sind der größte
discounter der welt wir bieten über
300.000 titel billiger die
meistverkauften titel das sind doppelt
so viele wie die größte physische
buchhandlung anbieten kann
aber die investoren waren frustriert der
umsatz stieg ohne gewinne amazon gab
millionen aus um software zu entwickeln
und das geschäft auszubauen
das unternehmen ging in dieser zeit
viele risiken ein und ich glaube es gab
viele spekulationen darüber dass das
richtige war oder nicht ist
es leicht zurück zu blicken und zu sagen
sie mussten so viel investieren um diese
größe zu erreichen die sie heute
aber das war nicht vom ersten tag an
klar
klar war das base nicht abzureißen basta
bongo
erhielt das tempo durch und trieb den
börsengang von amazon fahren die idee
war dass man sich nicht einen moment auf
seinen lorbeeren ausruht dass man
einfach ständig innovativ sein und sich
von der konkurrenz fernhalten muss und
keine millisekunde lang selbstgefällig
ist
am 15 mai 97 wurde die aktie an der
nasdaq börse zu einem preis von 29
dollar 25 pro aktie gehandelt
dollar über dem ausgabepreis
der tag des eigentlichen börsengangs war
eine echt große sache überall in der
firma gab es partys jeffrey coons aus
new york an und sagte wir haben heute
geschichte geschrieben
ihr habt alle heute geschichte
geschrieben es war verdammt aufregend
aber
trotz des gelungenen börsengangs hatten
tag analysten immer noch so ihre zweifel
tim o'reilly ist gründer und ceo von
o'reilly media
damals dachten viele dass amazon
untergehen würde sie nahmen die finanzen
genau unter die lupe und sagten dieses
unternehmen wird nie profitabel sein es
gab viele nein sager
amazon arbeite hart daran die website zu
aktualisieren und funktionen wie one
click shopping einzuführen
97 hat sich der aktienwert fast
vertreibt
er damals achte nicht auf den aktienkurs
er war zuversichtlich dass er auf lange
sicht immer weiter steigen würde aber er
hielt es für sehr gefährlich ihm
kurzfristig zu betrachten
amazon setzte seine rasante expansion
fort stellte über 7.000 mitarbeiter ein
und verstärkte seine produktpalette
wir haben über praktisch alles geredet
wie er könnten lebensmittel verkaufen
hygieneartikel handys und handytarife
zeitschriften und auch hardware
gartenschläuche und spielzeug das
größere angebot und der hohe absatz
zahlten sich aus für amazon.com als auch
für bessers
am zwanzigster dezember 99 wurde er vom
time magazine zur person des jahres
gekürt
meine mutter hat geweint
es war die ultimative bestätigung seines
traums die welt mit e commerce zu
erobern wenn sie durch das magazin
blättern sehen sie jeff als indiana
jones der an einer liane schwingt es
machte ihn in gewisser weise zu einem
amerikanischen volkshelden es ist als
hätte probanden den flur unter sein büro
das war ganz oben angekommen ist eine
katastrophe die ganze branche
erschüttert
ende der 90er jahre bei amazon eine
internet dampfwalze
aber im jahr 2000 platzte die blase
die aktienkurse brachen ein und schafft
es war zu drastischen maßnahmen
gezwungen
es gab zwei entlassungswellen und wie so
oft weiß man nicht wer gehen muss mann
kauert in seinem büro und wartet darauf
dass die personalabteilung kommt und mit
dem finger auf jemanden zeigt und es tut
weh kollegen geben zu sehen
angesichts des rückgangs der wirtschaft
und des verbrauchervertrauens war dass
die einzig vernünftige entscheidung die
wir treffen konnten
im september 2001 erreichte die aktie
des unternehmens ein allzeittief von
dort mit fünf dollar 97
vom aushängeschild zum prügelknaben
es ist nicht die art von aktien die man
besitzt und dann gut schläft wenn man
ein kleiner investor ist
für alle internet aktien
der vorteil den amazon hatte war sie
hatte sich sozusagen diese kriegskasse
angelegt um sowas finanzieren zu können
jesus hat hoch gewettet aber nicht alle
wetten haben sich ausgezahlt am anfang
hat das unternehmen lange keinen profit
gemacht der grund warum jeff bezos damit
durchkam war dass er immer direkt mit
seinen mitarbeitern und den
anteilseignern war
im januar 2002 begannen sich die wetten
endlich auszuzahlen
der aktienkurs erholte sich und nach
sieben jahren machte base unternehmen
endlich wieder gewinnen postete prof das
beste was ich über ihn sagen kann ist
seine unerschütterliche zuversicht
wusste dass die skeptiker zu kurzfristig
dachten sie seien nicht das große ganze
und er hielt immer an seine vision fest
als die blase geplatzt war hatten die
investoren keine geduld mehr für
unternehmen die sagten wir investieren
in den aufbau einer dot com seite in
unserem geschäft
das nutzte amazon aus und arbeitete mit
target und toys r us und gelb und
anderen einzelhändlern zusammen
der internethandels riese tat sich mit
mehr als 400 unternehmen zusammen aber
nicht alle einzelhändler waren willige
partner ich kenne eine reihe von fällen
in denen er unternehmen erworben hat um
potenzielle zukünftige wettbewerber
auszuschalten und nicht weil er deren
geschäft wirklich weiterführen wollte
merkel sonstigen themen es ist konnte
nachdem sein unternehmen wieder auf kurs
war konzentrierte sich bei sus auf eine
ganz andere leidenschaft und passion
am 6 märz 2003 startete er einen
helikopter um sich abgelegene gegenden
in texas anzuschauen
er wollte grundstücke kaufen für ein
technologieunternehmen das er im jahr
2000 gegründet hatte zum senkrechtstart
und senkrecht lande raketen für die
bemannte raumfahrt zu entwickeln
die reise endete fast in einer
katastrophe
kurz nach dem start geriet der
helikopter ins trudeln und landete in
einem flussbett
[Musik]
2003 starb jeff bezos fast bei einem
hubschrauberabsturz
es ist wie ein muster er macht etwas
schlimmes durch wie einen internet crash
und dann philosophiert er darüber und
lachte es einfach weg des babys war
im gegensatz zur space exploration
ventures das von privaten geldgebern wie
elon musk richard branson und john
carmack finanziert wird ist besessen
davon blue origin gering zu halten
es war aus verschiedenen gründen
ziemlich geheimnisvoll und dass sich der
raumfahrtindustrie ist das eigentlich
schade was einen guten markt ausmacht
ist wenn ein haufen konkurrenten offen
miteinander konkurriert und versucht
sich gegeneinander zu positionieren sie
konkurrieren um geld sie konkurrieren um
menschen
nach sechs jahren arbeit hinter
verschlossenen türen hoch die seltsam
aussehende testrakete von blue origin
[Applaus]
und james war dabei einen weiteren
revolutionären versuch zu starten
diesmal weniger weit weg
das war eine gelegenheit die buchbranche
enorm zu erweitern und die definition
dessen was ein buch sein kann aber es
brauchte jemanden mit ausreichend
schlagkraft um diese zusammenführung von
hardware software durchzuführen
nur amazon war in der lage das zu tun am
19 november 2007 namen base an der
talkshow teil und kündigte ein
bahnbrechendes neues produkt
ich hatte hier in händen wovon wir reden
es heißt tindall sagen sie mir wann sie
zum ersten mal auf die idee kam dass so
etwas möglich sein würde
und zwar klar geworden dass es einige
technologien gab die irgendwie zusammen
und dass wir mit dem richtigen rezept
etwas erschaffen konnten von dem wir
hoffen das ist die welt des
elektronischen lesens verändern würde
dann hat dieses gerät auf den markt
gebracht ebenso viele der ästhetischen
vorteile von echten büchern fehlten du
kannst die seiten nicht mehr riechen
keine eselsohren mehr rein machen aber
all die buch liebhaber die dieses ding
gefürchtet haben lieben es jetzt
der 399 dollar teure reader war nur
fünfeinhalb stunden ausverkauft
die genauen verkaufszahlen bleiben
allerdings ein streng gehütetes
geheimnis vom unternehmen heißt es man
wolle sie nicht veröffentlicht
winfried melzer ceo von harper collins
und das mitbegründerin von open road
integrated media
niemand weiß wie viele kinder ist es
wirklich gibt es ist ein ratespiel wir
wissen dass es millionen gibt aber wie
viele millionen aber es ist
offensichtlich die strategie von amazon
sie halten viele informationen unter
verschluss aber
für viele verlage war der kindle ein
branchenkenner
es wird in den nächsten jahren echtes
blut im verlagswesen fließen weil die
verlage nicht früh genug bemerkt haben
dass amazon an konkurrent ist
[Musik]
während der kindle große wellen auf dem
e-book-markt schlug bereitete amazon
seiner bisher größte
unternehmensakquisition von
dotkomm amerika führendem online
schuhhändler
als ich 2004 jeff bezos zum ersten mal
traf sagte er sei daran interessiert
sehr bus zu kaufen damals sagten wir
werden kein interesse sein wie seine
identität verlieren würde
zögerte an amazon zu verkaufen
sie haben sich wieder bei uns gemeldet
und gesagt dass sie sich auch vorstellen
könnten dass wir unabhängig bleiben
es wurde klar dass könnten wirklich
großartige partner sein
im sommer 2009 kaufte amazon den
angesagten online schuhhändler nein
investoren erhielten zehn millionen
aktien
sie bekamen aktien die zu diesem
zeitpunkt besser als bargeld waren und
das zeigt dass jeff bezos jemand ist der
die konkurrenz über rollen kann wenn es
sein muss der aber auch bereit es zu
verhandeln und zu bekommen was er will
und dabei aber alle reicher zu machen
der schuh fasste aber ein goldesel der
kinder bekam ernsthafte konkurrenz von
einem technologieriesen
und wenn am 27 januar 2010 brachte apple
das ipad auf dem markt das auch als
lesegerät passiert war
base reagierte aggressiv senkte die
kosten und fügte seinem e-reader neue
funktionen hinzu eine sache die besseres
als amazon chef schon immer gerne getan
hat ist das spielen mit sehr engen
maschen
die preissenkung des kindle zeigt das
besser erkannt hatte wurde er wirklich
langfristige gewinn für amazon liegt
nämlich der anbieter zu sein wo jeder
seine bücher kauft und der kindle ist
das gerät mit dem man sie bekommt
das wachstum des e book markt das
animierte viele bücher
amazon.com amazoncom auf die bühne und
wurde zum konkurrenten der einzelhändler
sie waren jetzt der händler
das unternehmen borders hätte ihr
untergang sein können aber der
buchhändler hat seinem gesamten
digitalen verkauf über amazon
abgewickelt hätte er seine eigene
präsenz aufgebaut wäre die situation
heute
die angaben der autoren innung kaufte
amazon bücher im großhandel für 12 bis
13 dollar und verkaufte sie als kindle
bücher für neun euro 99 machte also
jedes mal verlust
wetterte gegen dieses
wenn ein buch 10 dollar wert ist sei es
ein preis reduziert deshalb bei hermes
ein e-book für den kindle wenn wir jetzt
bei 10 dollar sind dann wird sich die
ganze branche verändern wir werden
verlagert wir werden buchhandlung
verlieren
andere sahen darin eine gelegenheit
sehen sie sich all die autoren haben die
durch dem kindle die möglichkeit bekamen
eine direkte kundenbeziehungen
aufzubauen
ich glaube das macht amazon zum gewinner
des ganzen weil sie eine brücke zwischen
autoren und lesern gebaut haben die es
bisher so nicht gegeben hat
das meldete insolvenz an und auch bahn
sind nobel die größte buchhandelskette
hatte zu kämpfen
2011 von dot com außerdem in dem video
streaming markt ein
tv redakteur für das magazin variety
ich glaube wenn sie netflix sind sehen
sie in amazon einen echten konkurrenten
amazon hat online viel anziehungskraft
sie haben tiefe taschen um genau so
viele titel zu kaufen sie stehen hier
zwar noch ganz am anfang aber mit der
zeit könnte amazon genau so groß werden
wie netflix
die doch der internet riese ist mit
wachsendem widerstand gegen seinen
unversteuerten online-umsatz
konfrontiert
mehrere staaten verlangen lokale
umsatzsteuersatz zeigt sich
unbeeindruckt und macht ein paar
hat seine finger in jedermanns kuchen er
hat videostreaming das mit netflix
konkurriert er macht musik die mit apple
und itunes konkurriert gerückt sogar mit
einem eigenen app store google auf die
pelle
etwas sieht mit dem amazon ein bisschen
geld verdienen und seinen dünnen margen
helfen kann dann wird er es tun
er hat es weit gebracht und sein
weltraum projekt sogar noch weiter
april 2011 bekam blue origin 22
millionen dollar von der nasa und tücken
die entwicklung seines raum fahrzeug
bloomberg setzt asus auf platz 20 der
reichsten menschen der welt mit einem
geschätzten nettovermögen von 25
milliarden dollar
amazon.com bleibt der weltweit größte
online händler
er ist nicht nur ein visionär er ist ein
architekt mit verlieren und einer
vorstellung davon wie man dinge zum
laufen bringt er denkt sehr sorgfältig
über design struktur und betrieb nach
und das macht aus einem diesem jahr
jemand der tatsächlich etwas
hätte amazon barnes and noble oder an
andere buchhändler verkaufen und viele
millionen dollar machen können sowie mit
anfang 30 seitdem
ich konnte immer wieder mit richtig
guten ideen
diese nahe beijing
er ist nicht der harte typ der über
leichen geht er ist jemand der seine
vision hat wie er dieses unternehmen
aufbauen möchte und er ist in der lage
sich mit leuten zu umgeben die sich
darauf einlassen
ich denke dass es letztendlich einer der
gründe warum er so erfolgreich ist
[Musik]